you're 52 years old it's not being
talked about enough that hey man hey gal
it's not over figure out the opportunity
at hand go attack it you only live once
when you're 90 to 100 years old and
you're regretting that you never built
this business and you let this era pass
this moment where there's so much
entrepreneurial upside you'll regret it
and regret is the worst and I believe
more than ever that if you're 49 year
old or two kids because of this phone
you've got more opportunities to create
something for yourself you've got the
right DNA and you're a 72 year old
female you're just as good of it as a 27
year old dude but you've been trained
and story told to and positioned and
lived in a 50-year manner that doesn't
feel like this thing in here is a
practical way to build that but it is